[Music]
right as we continue the special edition
of Hannity now during the Muller
witch-hunt they destroy Trump media mob
hysterically breathlessly running with
one fake news story after another
pushing a false narrative pushing
conspiracy theories about Trump Russia
collusion we have four investigations
out including the Muller a report that
conclude it didn't happen but it went on
for too long solid years plus remember
this we're about to find out if the new
president of our country is going to do
what Russia wants as if there are no
shoes on the Trump Human Centipede that
are not about Russia Russia Russia
Russia this cloud about collusion with
Russia will hang over him no matter
where he stands I think they're shocked
that the noose is tightening it's clear
that mother is now connecting the dots
between a massive obstruction intended
to hide the truth Donald Trump's time
he's done there's no question about he's
got to know his future looks like it's
behind bars we have a treasonous
president we now have to figure out how
to deal with a President of the United
States who wittingly or unwittingly has
been compromised presidency is
effectively a Russian op it's really
sick and on multiple occasions the fake
news media reported just outright
falsehoods take a look get the person's
phone records here they see these calls
to the block number and now there seems
to be good evidence that that was
probably President Trump we begin with a
new report that Paul man afford the
president's former campaign chairman
paid secret visits multiple ones to
Julian Assange at the Ecuadorian Embassy
in London this is according to the
Guardian president Trump directed his
attorney to lie to Congress so the
liberal mainstream media mob has become
nothing more than an extension a branch
of all things radical extreme democratic
socialist party as they echo now every
single talking point of that party as
news Buster points out mark also writes
about in his book the media recently
echoed this this democratic
looking point that there was a
constitutional crisis over the Trump
administration standing up to House
committee subpoenas and the media they
repeated it nearly 400 times they talk
and speak in unison listen so President
Trump is pursuing a stone wall strategy
when it comes to Congress in courting a
constitutional crisis but the honey
badger president just doesn't care or
certainly approaching a constitutional
crisis we're hovering on a
constitutional crisis President Trump
appears to be heading toward a
constitutional crisis where America is
dangerously close to a constitutional
crisis mark Levins brand-new book on
freedom of the press I call him the
great one
before I get to the rush of collusion
stuff I want to go back 515 election
night 2016 I talked to you I also talked
to Donald Trump I said somebody's
drawing straws right now and they're
gonna bring you in news is horrible that
you didn't win a single state basically
exit polls were wrong in o4 they were
just wrong recently in Israel but more
importantly when the media coverage
started on that election night they were
giddy you could see it they had it in a
bag Hillary won
they beat Trump the night progressed you
could see a visible shift in mood too
nearly going off the ledge
does that not prove what you're saying
in this book
do your montage is not proven exactly
it's groupthink it's a pack mentality
it is ideologies going in one direction
you can't find a dimes worth a
difference between the media and the
Democrat Party in this country look at
the guests they bring it one of the
great problems 1942 there was a
commission where the media looked at the
media the media never look at the media
today but the media actually looked at
the media this is in the book and this
is all look and what they said is they
gave a blaring alarm and said one of the
great fears we have is the mixture of
opinion with news I point out in this
book there's a study by the Shorenstein
Center at Harvard it's not right-wing
not left-wing it is what it is and they
study the media they looked at the first
hundred days of the coverage of Donald
Trump
you know what they found 90% of the
coverage was negative on CNN and NBC
over 80% New York Times Washington Post
nobody was below the mid 70% range
except Fox there was 50 to 48 percent
negative positive about as even-handed
as you can get on the news side there's
no distinction between news and opinion
on these other networks it's hard to
find distinction between news and
opinion in the front pages of the New
York Times in the Washington Post I'll
give you a few more examples actually
yeah you quoted I think it was a
political article in the in the book the
first time they talked about impeachment
was April of 2016 they were talking
about for how many months out of the
election they've been talking about
impeachment since he was a candidate
this idea of a constitutional crisis I
spent my life working on the
Constitution you have a lot of
individuals in Congress who have no
comprehension what they're talking about
and so they get a lot of airtime on
MSNBC and CNN they got a lot of a lot of
time on the pages of the New York Times
and The Washington Post just because
Congress issues dozens and dozens of
subpoenas doesn't mean the subpoenas are
legitimate and in this case they're
intentionally illegitimate they're all
personal they're all aimed at citizen
Trump they're all violations of
separation of powers the president has
an obligation not just for himself but
to protect the office of the presidency
in the executive branch it is mr. Nadler
who's the dictator is mr. Schiff who's
the dictator they are the demagogues who
are all over TV these are not objective
individuals these are not people looking
for the truth they don't care how if
they cared about how the IRS handled
presidential tax returns why did they
care about it when Barack Obama was
president the United States how couldn't
they is lawmakers smart talk about the
sergeant of arms putting the Attorney
General of the United States bringing
put them in handcuffs bring them over to
the committee when all the Attorney
General is saying is I will not break
the law you're the law and they're the
lawmakers if it gets to that point let
me remind these tough guys in the house
I don't know when I look at Nadler I
think tough guy don't you oh yeah look
at chef I think toughest
very crazy picked all over the yeah but
in any event let me suggest to the house
stop the stupid comments I suggest you
the Justice Department has a lot more
manpower and firepower than the House of
Representatives a skew this yeah so we
go through this two-year Muller
investigation we have now had a
nine-month FBI investigation no
collusion the house Intel committee long
invest no collusion no conspiracy we
went through the bipartisan Senate
committee
now the Muller report the same thing and
they want to keep going
how and my question to you is
ninety-nine point nine percent of the
people in the media went with the hoax
conspiracy theory the lying and a
narrative that was based on false
information okay there were a few of us
you're part of this this group that may
be twenty five in the country we did it
on my radio and TV show you did it on
yours rush did it on his Gregg Jarrett
Sarah Carter G Jenna I can't name
everybody and the point is this they got
it wrong Hillary's investigation was
rigged they didn't report it can I
interrupt it they didn't report it they
didn't get it wrong this is what they
wanted to do they don't care about right
and wrong they're driven by ideology
when you're driven by ideology but they
reported it wrong purposely they want to
take the president out they decide
what's in the news what's left out of
the news that's why for them there's a
red line and all these issues involving
the dossier all these issues involving
spying they dismiss them they dismiss
the people who speak about it they
dismiss the words this is an
ideologically driven let me tell you
little story give you a little
historical context on chapter six the
Holocaust six million Jews are
slaughtered others are slaughtered the
New York Times barely covered it the New
York Times barely covered the Holocaust
the New York Times is
own a Jewish family it barely covered
the Holocaust because mr. Souls burger
decided he didn't want his newspaper to
be seen as sort of a Jewish newspaper he
wanted the newspaper to be more of a
universal newspaper if TR didn't want to
focus on the Holocaust so the New York
Times complied they wouldn't accept
evidence that was coming was being
printed in in European publications they
pretended the evidence was not quality
evidence it wasn't good enough people
had escaped first-hand accounts for the
most part they ignored it three scholars
in particular written about this how
many people know that the New York Times
self-centred when he came to the
Holocaust ten years before when Stalin
was slaughtering the Ukrainians and
starving them to death
they had a correspondent in Moscow by
the name of Walter Durant he got a
Pulitzer Prize for his reporting covered
up the slaughter that Stalin had
committed against the Ukraine this is
the New York Times can any other
business in the country survive that let
alone be called the paper of record all
the news that's fit to print
the New York Times still hasn't
significantly and seriously dealt with
this it keeps its Pulitzer Prize two
massive genocides in the last century
you wouldn't find a hell a lot about of
it in the pages of the New York Times at
the time that's the kind of media that
we're talking about what makes this book
so good because you bring it from its
history to modern day we're going to
continue the great ones mark levin on
freedom of the press by the way
amazon.com bookstores everywhere it's up
on my website Hannity com